- So what inspired you to do this?
- I started walking across America
because I wanted to be
somebody I was proud of.
You know if somebody said
to me, who is your hero?
Or who inspires you?
I wanted to be able to look
them in the eye and say me.
I'm my hero.
(audience applauding)
- Is it just like setting a goal
and finishing it and completing it?
- That's certainly part of it.
- Yeah.
- You know out there you get
to have a no matter what clause
in that contract with yourself,
because you do something like that,
and things can and will
definitely go wrong.
- Yeah.
- Over that time period.
- I heard you had a scary
incident that happened.
- Yeah, when I was about not even halfway.
I was in eastern Colorado, so
a very flat part of Colorado.
And I came out of our support vehicle
and I got bit by a rattlesnake.
(audience groaning)
- Which is deadly.
- Yeah, if you don't get
to the hospital in time,
it could kill you.
Most people survive.
- And you're probably
in the middle of nowhere.
- I was definitively in the
middle of nowhere, yeah.
(audience laughing)
Basically yeah, I was 30
miles from the last town,
about 60 miles from the next town.
(audience groaning)
- [Kelly] Oh wow, look at the gnarly foot!
- Ooh.
- Oh!
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, so that was
a few days later.
- That's how my feet
looked when I was pregnant.
(audience laughing)
- That's real.
I didn't have to walk
anywhere, it just happened.
So how long did it take
you to recover from that?
- It took me about three weeks.
So I went from doing 24
miles a day down to zero.
So I just started building
my way up from the bathroom
and then they let me go home.
So I used the walker
to get to the kitchen.
And then eventually I was
walking down the street.
And then one mile, and two miles.
And--
- You picked it right back up.
- I went, I had to go
back to the same spot
where I got bit to finish my journey.
Because--
- Did you start
with the middle finger?
(audience laughing)
I would've.
Been like, take that, snake!
(audience laughing)
- I was actually pretty scared to go back.
I didn't wanna go back there,
but I knew I had made
this commitment to myself,
and like I said, I was doing that
to be somebody I was actually proud of.
And somebody I was actually proud of,
that person he doesn't quit.
- How did it feel when
you got to Venice Beach?
(audience applauding)
First of all I'm gonna start walking
if I can get a waist like that, okay.
Mama's gonna be walking
all day, all night, okay.
How was it being on the beach?
That was pretty cool, you finished it.
You accomplished it.
- Yeah, it was definitely
one of the best moment
of my life, for sure,
to make it there.
- Yeah.
- But at the same time,
even though I finished
my walk across America,
I'm not done.
I had an inkling before I left that
there was more inside me.
And what I found out is
I was actually wrong.
It's not just a little bit more,
it's like way more.
And so even though my walk is over,
my journey is not.
And I'm not particularly
interested in becoming
an old fat dude who says,
remember that one time
I did something cool?
- (laughing) I love you.
- I don't wanna be that guy.
I don't even really wanna meet that guy.
I have no interest in him.
- You should make another album
and call it five million steps.
(audience laughing)
I'm just saying.
- I'd download that.
- Do y'all have something
that's huge like that
on your bucket list?
- Woo, my bucket list was to meet a man
who has walked 2,500 miles.
So I got that done.
There you go.
- Check.
- Also to dance backup
one day for Beyonce.
- Yeah!
- Yes.
And I mean like, I don't mind
if it's all the way backed up,
like behind the curtain.
- Oh,
'cause you're a Houston girl, too?
B is too?
- Yes.
- That's right.
- And I just wanna witness
those quads in person, that's all.
(audience laughing)
- I'm telling you, you tell
Beyonce get billions of views
you being in the next video.
- I got you girl.
- Yes.
I don't know if I'd want
to dance next to Beyonce.
Unless it was a comedy.